in diesen sekunden kommt joe biden fuß
mikrofon dort ans pult und wir hören
live rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so wachsen dass wir auf dem richtigen
weg sind um diese wahlen zu gewinnen
[Applaus]
wir wissen ja so viele so früh gewählt
haben dass es eine ganze weile dauern
würde und wir müssen geduld zeigen
bis dann alles ausgezählt ist und wir
wissen dass jede stimme gezählt werden
muss jede einzelne stimme zählt
[Musik]
aber wir fühlen uns immer noch gut wir
für uns gut damit wo wir jetzt stehen
wir glauben dass wir vielleicht arizona
schon gewonnen haben da sehen wir dass
es gut aussieht das ist eine wende
minnesota haben wir gerade geld bekommen
und georgia nicht schlecht aus das haben
wir nicht erwartet
wir fühlen uns richtig gut was michigan
und wisconsin angeht
und außerdem es wird lange dauern bis
die stimmen ausgezählt sind aber dann
gewinnen wir pennsylvania sind das hier
ganz viel passiert werden sehen wer mit
vielen gesprochen hinaus passiert wir
können diese ergebnisse vielleicht erst
morgen vormittag bekommen es kann auch
vielleicht noch länger dauern vielleicht
sehr lange es ist nicht aufgabe zu
erklären wir gewaltiger sondern die
aufgabe des volkes ich möchte allen
danken ihnen allen die in diesen wahlen
ihre stimme abgegeben haben und
teilgenommen haben und die auch hier in
delaware sind
[Applaus]
das ganze team sie haben fantastisch
gearbeitet ich bin sehr dankbar alle die
gearbeitet haben in den wahllokalen die
an der kampagne mitgearbeitet haben die
dieses wunderbare kampagne organisiert
haben
und ich möchte in allen in der ganzen
nation danken vielen dank danke danke
und leute sie haben schon gehört dass
ich gesagt habe
jedes mal wenn ich aus dem haus weil es
groß war das kommt auch das gesicht zu
nach vorne und wir können es schaffen
wir sollen uns zusammenreißen wir können
es noch schaffen danke danke vielen dank
die geduld hier ist fantastisch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ok also dieses kurzes statement von joe
biden der meinte es ist nicht meine
aufgabe nicht meinen platz sieg oder
niederlage einzugestehen und auch nicht
von donald trump damit hat er ja der
ganzen sache schon vorgebaut und
praktisch die entscheidung für diese
wahl verschoben auf den auf die gerichte
auf die wähler die dann doch noch
ausgezählt werden
sie habe damit genau gemeint hat wäre
das jetzt entscheiden soll das hat er
uns vergessen zu verraten er hat
tatsächlich gesagt es ist nicht an uns
den sieg zu erklären dass ja kann man
unterschiedlich sehen also es gibt
durchaus wahlergebnisse bei denen es
vollkommen legitim ist sein wahlsieg zu
erklären dafür gibt es ja diese klare
margin von 270 stimmen aber das was ich
eigentlich faszinierend fand nur zwar
was hat er uns da eigentlich nach diesem
jahr auch für ihn nerven aufreibenden
tag seines seiner politischen karriere
47 jahre in der politik jetzt nachdem er
schon acht jahre als vizepräsident an
der seite von barack obama ist im weißen
haus scheinbar scheinbar so nach 223
stimmen bei der ep 237 stimmen bei fox
news also nur noch wenige stunden
entfernt von dieser magischen 270 und
doch das was ich daraus gehört habe
klang nicht jemand der vom sieg
überzeugt war es war jemand der gesagt
hat wir wollen heute gar nicht mehr
sagen wer gewonnen hat ungewöhnlich wenn
man an den sieg glaubt zwei sätze die
mich besonders auf feuchten dass ein
kippte face glaubt weiter dran naja das
ist jetzt nicht gerade das was man sagt
wenn man davon überzeugt ist dass man
das ding gewinnen wird und dann
innovatives konnte das ist nicht vorbei
bis wirklich jede wahl gezählt ist es
ist nicht vorbei bis jede wahl gezählt
ist das trinkt fast ein bisschen er nach
durchhalteparole
als nach einem wirklichen glauben daran
er hat uns aber auch aufgezeigt und ein
bisschen verraten einblicke gegeben das
was sein team team beiden gerade da in
delaware sich anguckt und das ist
vielleicht interessant für wir haben
gerade gesehen in unseren tagen viele
viele menschen die jetzt gerade
einschalten jetzt gerade aufgewacht sind
mutig an verschiedenen geräten auf den
verschiedenen seiten so wie wir jetzt
selber auch dieses herzschlagfinale um
die us-präsidentschaft mitverfolgen hat
uns einen einblick gegeben worauf es
jetzt zu achten gilt
er hat minister genannten minnesota hat
er gewonnen minnesota ist drin in diesem
237 stimmen und wie gesagt damit braucht
es noch 33 stimmen bis ins oval office
und dann hat er uns gesagt worauf guckt
team beiden gerade und das sind
wisconsin michigan er sagt pennsylvania
wird lange dauern aber wir werden
pennsylvania gewinnen und auch georgia
gucken sie noch drauf das ist so eine
art also ein rechter winkel den wir da
auf der karte sehen einmal von oben im
nordosten der usa diese drei rosa
staaten und dann runter nach otto
interessant sein weg zum sieg so wie wir
es eben analysiert haben besteht daraus
eine konstellation aus diesen staaten zu
gewinnen in denen er aber gerade zurück
liegt nach einhelliger zählung aller
unterschiedlichen nachrichtenquellen
also was könnte er zum beispiel im auge
haben pennsylvania mit sind 20 stimmen
pennsylvania der staat mit den meisten
stimmen der noch zu vergeben ist
pennsylvania möchte im moment jeder
haben geht auch ohne pennsylvania das
ist das was er uns da aufgezeigt hat mit
pennsylvania bräuchte er zwei staaten
ohne pennsylvania wo ich der drei start
zum beispiel wisconsin michigan und da
unten georgia auch das wäre ein
möglicher weg zum sieg vermutlich daher
gesagt hatten auch pennsylvania kommt
das pennsylvania werden wir heute nicht
mehr aus zielen zählte ein bisschen
darauf mit diesen drei staat wisconsin
michigan und georgia den 270 stimmen
sagt trotzdem schon zu zwischen nur wie
gesagt das was joe biden und da als sein
path to victory aufgezeigt hat sind drei
bis vier staaten in denen er gerade
hinten bis deutlich hinten liegt das ist
keine besonders optimistische
perspektive und deswegen vielleicht auch
diese sätze gibt so face glaubt weiter
dran und dahinter over till rehwaldt es
kaum mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren